this date sports history this is 19
since 1995
Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the third he
scores what eight points in nine seconds
against the New York Knicks how often
you get asked about that Reggie just
about every venue I walk into to
announce a game somebody brings up that
game or they'll come up with the choke
sign start laughing or they swear
they're the biggest Knicks fan and if
they hate me but they respect me so I
get it from all sides but it's funny
because when I call games and games were
coming down the stretch and teams are
down by six or seven points always in
the back of my mind I say oh yeah it's
not only as I've seen funnier things and
that was one of those perfect storms
where things just kind of came together
what did you do after the game I went
back to my little nestled place The
Plaza Hotel and ordered a service and in
the playoffs sure always hold up so that
was that was it you couldn't have gone
out I believe that was gay I believe
that was Game one and I remember I made
the remark about John Starks choking so
the headlines of X Bay was be called on
John Starks choking glitch everyone knew
they did because I think it was a
headline which I get yeah I would just
hold up at the Plaza yeah you couldn't
have been walking the street so I don't
think New Yorkers would have been
thinking too highly of that if they saw
out at that time no mark again we talked
about this year and our bar Jackson was
my eyes he was the one that would go out
and infiltrate he's a mask
we're thinking so he brought me these
papers so I could read and get fired up
and things like that you ever talked to
John Starks about that moment I'm not
about that moment but you know what I've
done mixed games what they were
irrelevant and actually all networks a
few years
we'd go into the garden he works for the
Knicks so we would have a somewhat
friendly conversation we're cool I
respect John John was one of the
fiercest guys I've ever done against and
I respect that I respect guys that lay
it on the line it would do whatever it
takes to win but we're cool no reg
called game four last night Rockets in
the Jazz he'll be on duty game five
tomorrow night in Houston at 8:00
Eastern on TNT
I love the jazz story they just don't
have the weapons to compete here I'd
love to see them win another game but I
just don't think it's gonna happen your
takeaway from this series is one percent
right not enough weapons and you know
you hate to say this but they're
bringing a knife to a gunfight Houston
has too many weapons they have the three
best players in this series disrespect
to the rookie and Donovan Mitchell but
James Hart number one in my opinion
number two has been quick capela and
what he has done at both ends of the
floor especially defensively and
obviously the birthday boy yesterday
Chris Paul they've got the three best
players they're well coached and they've
got role players that understand their
roles significantly and defensively
people don't like to talk about this
with the Houston Rockets but defensively
they're finding ways to win ballgames
and they check you and lock you down so
this heavyweight fight that we are all
want to see in the Western Conference
both teams are one win away from the
Western Conference fight also facing one
another in Golden State and the Houston
Rockets the Hamptons five is now there
now known is that the best starting five
in the last 40 years I mean it's the
worst name but is that the best starting
five in the last 40 years in the last 40
years
yes 35 yes so curry Durant
three dream on Klay yeah
look last 40 years look you see I like
go ahead Joe Dumars Isaiah what Rodman
my dear I they are
how about Magic's worthy Byron Scott
cream okay which one would you take I'm
gonna I'm gonna I didn't even put the
Pistons in here and I should Byrd McHale
parish Dennis Johnson Danny Ainge Bill
Walton was Sixth Man of the Year he came
off the bench 87 you had Kareem Magic
worthy Byron Scott and AC green 96 Bulls
Jordan Pippen Rodman Harper Longley 2011
Heat Wade Bosh LeBron Big Z and Chalmers
and then you throw in the bad boys of
the Pistons in there which sneaky
underrated I would say with the Zeke and
Dumars Hall of Famers in the backcourt
lame ear
Laimbeer Rodman do we have mark Ag wire
in there as well our glider marker glare
I would take all those teams other than
that Miami team over the Warriors
starting five all those teams you
mentioned other than that that Miami -
hmm let's face it Stu that's starting
five for the Golden State Warriors
that's a whole lineup
yeah can you think about them going
against that Boston Celtic or that LA
Laker Kareem magic and worthy team I
mean those guys well now don't get me
wrong
they are quick athletic but again
depends on what rules were flying with
80 90 thousand to Bolivia but I would
still take all those other teams other
than that my own a team over Golden
State well if you're doing old school
rules then I'm gonna take those teams
I'll take the 87 Lakers 86 Celtics I'll
take the bad boys of the early 90s but
if I'm playing today alright just I was
curious about that reg has the call
that'll be tomorrow night in Houston
that'll be Game five the LeBron runner
as beautiful as it was clutch as it was
I can't every time I see a star
Claire hit a shot and there's single
coverage on him I just want to scream
reg I I know he's coming out you had
full force there's two guys who started
on him one guy sags off and then LeBron
hits the runner like I want him taking a
going left shooting back right off the
glass I want that but I want DeMarre
Rosen out there somebody athletic on him
like I can't believe that they let
LeBron even have a look like that reg
number one the degree of difficulty and
the shock that you just highlighted I
mean driving left full-speed shooting
back right and oh by the way I work all
day unbelievable but you're right the
problem is they took the ball full court
they didn't take it out on the side
where you have a better chance of
doubling him and get the ball out of his
hand when he was going left did you see
who was at that left corner
Kyle Cora of course no no reg I like
before beat me I'm not letting LeBron
James beat me if Kyle Korver hits it I
will salute him so then right now what
you're calling in question I agree with
you you gotta get the ball out of his
head I can't have LeBron have it I can't
I just
i-i'll deal with that if Kyle Korver
hits that three then you know what good
for him I want the guys who don't
normally take those shots and you know
okay
the NBA learn when to lift so what
you're saying is should someone have
gotten the ball out of sabayon Russell
and John Stockton and Malone got the
ball out of Michael Jordan iconic shot
at the free-throw line off the push off
yes same scenario one on one up top
maybe go to work yes by the way that's
playing find a way to get that off reg
you got to pick up your dry gotta make
you pick up your dribble I have to do
that as everybody the NBA found out when
Jordan got the ball against the Cavs and
went through a double-team and then add
single coverage with Craig Ehlo hung hit
the shot I would never want Jordan to
beat me again and you had Paxson who had
a big shot and Steve Kerr who had big
in there Bulls careers because people
did double-team Mike and make sure that
he didn't get the shot but Utah but it
didn't
Utah should have doubled it they should
have doubled it they should have done
still
crazy but I'm sure look he's a willing
pastor the game if they woulda came home
Korver wide open
short corner three Kyle Korver you have
any percent of the time wide open I
don't care I don't care
LeBron's not beating me not not beating
well number one look he is in the
Raptors head and this is bad seriously
because now you're in your best players
head as well is demar derozan for demar
derozan not to play the fourth quarter
your best player crazy your all-star
crazy you've got to be on the floor so
so look a lot of mistakes down the
stretch by Dwayne Casey and staff not
having your best player on the floor
with that length I mean he's the one guy
that probably if you didn't want to cut
a double you would probably want the
Martha Rosen on LeBron James right at
least yes yes because if you gotta have
your best player on the floor that time
and people don't realize that you want
him to go left to go back right so at
least you're playing back into the
defender if you go back right you know
ideally you want that runner as a
right-handed shooter going right to be
able to extend a little further away
from the defender and get it off the
glass he went left came back and then
had the kiss off the glass that's where
I want two guys on him and I certainly
went tomorrow DeRozan on him even if
he's you know pouting or slumping at
least I got a guy who's got some length
there to you know challenge it or double
teaming see that's a heck of a shot
though man you were prey during the
course of the game he would pray that he
would take shots like that it's just so
happens he's making those in theory yeah
now it's been an unbelievable series you
know that they barely escaped Indiana
then you would think Toronto you know
best record home court advantage you
know and then we in let's say they move
on and Boston moves on Boston has home
court advantage here I know that Vegas
Vegas really the Cavs are a big favorite
against the Celtics here do you see it
that way if that's how this plays out I
do I do
and I look you asked me this last week
after it
Cleveland wrapped up that Indiana series
I could not have been more wrong I just
thought with the length and the depth of
Toronto playing nine ten deep that they
were gonna wear the Cavs down but when
they stole Game one and they had no
business winning Game one and then they
pumped them in Game two the writing's on
the wall and it's we didn't factor in
the psyche of Toronto because we needed
to ask ourselves what have the Raptors
done all they've done in the playoffs is
disappoint us right yeah that's all
we've done so why was he given a long
leash why was I given them a lot leashes
as opposed to looking at the pedigree
not as LeBron but of the Cavaliers
kennel of there's been a sighting right
he found his game he found this and she
understands he's the number two guy on
this team now so I could not have been
more wrong
and yes the Cavs would be I wouldn't say
a heavy favorite because we're not
giving Brad Stephen and the Celtics IQ
all the players the Celtics IQ of being
able to win ballgames they just say fine
plays and they're young and they're
energetic and I don't know if they don't
even know any better but they play the
right way they play well off of one
another and that's what makes us so
David dangerous so I wouldn't say the
Cavs are a heavy favorite I think it'd
be a great series just because of the
fact of what Brad Stevens has done as a
coach to bring out the best in a Terry
Rozier and a Horford and I mean they
just plain I mean the rookie Tatum Jimmy
Brown playing hurt I give them all the
credit
I'm looking at LeBron's numbers in the
playoffs he's averaging just under 35
nine and a half rebounds
almost
nine assists one-and-a-half steals
shootings your MVP now don't you wish
you could factor in postseason and James
Harden has been just as fantastic for
Houston but if you had to pick an MVP
right now and include the first you know
six seven eight games for each team
who's your MVP LeBron was my MVP but but
I said Harden has earned it he's earned
the right but LeBron is the most
valuable player in the league
it just is he's the best player and he's
the most valuable player in the league
Harden is a new story and argue he
deserves to be the MVP just like
Westbrook got his opportunity but
there's nobody on those other teams if
you put him on the Cavs they could do
what LeBron is doing and if I put LeBron
on Oklahoma City they're still playing
if I put him on the Rockets they're
gonna be the favorites in the West so
you know that's just LeBron Harden is
not getting the Cavs to the Eastern
Conference Finals in my opinion or
Russell Westbrook jr. that there I agree
not evidence I agree yeah
and that's that's what Michael Michael
Jordan fell into that the years that
caramel don't want it twice and Charles
Barkley wanted that one year those were
my MVP yes right yes but you know he
showed that in the finals when he played
them one final note here we had Frank
Isola on who covers the Knicks for the
New York Daily News he said part of the
reason why the Knicks have hired David
phys Dale is his connection with LeBron
James we have not factored in the Knicks
with any a big-name high priced free
agents in recent memory why would this
be different that should we be including
the Knicks in the possible destinations
for LeBron no no no LeBron is not gonna
play for the Knicks
sorry Knicks fans you got a great hire
indeed at this Dell great coats great
extra zone I thought he got a raw deal
in Memphis but LeBron James and the
Knicks absolutely positively won't
happen yeah excellent and in fact this
is hurting all these other teams like
Houston or Philadelphia the success of
what Cleveland is doing right now
because if they wouldn't went out
against Indiana or found a way to lose
versus Toronto yeah didn't give you like
you know what the broad did the best you
possibly could with this roster
but what he's doing now and probably
what other free agents are seeing you
know what this dude still has a lock on
the Eastern Conference for the next
three or four years let me go let me go
to Cleveland and play with him safe
travels reg good to talk to you have fun
tomorrow night in Houston see door
you're the best and you know what guys
we because I am v Bennett we are gonna
win that Sports Emmy we're winning it
Hank
if this show wins New York we will win
hey I'm getting you you're gonna get a
sports inning just for the aspirin slide
because you guys do the heavy lifting at
all no no no no no no you're you're our
sixth man but you're the fifth Dan end
you're coming off the bench the
microwave we didn't even factor in the
microwave with that pistons bad boys man
thank you now are you taking them over
curry you could make a case you could
make a case yeah that that Pistons team
is as talented as any team in the last
30 years thank you you could make I got
John Salley coming off they were
absolutely number one they were the
toughest and meanest team over the last
30 years no one comes close did they try
to hurt you intentionally what do you
think I'll walk with the limp right now
[Laughter]
that was your gangster lean I didn't
know that you were walking with a limp
because of the Pistons you think I walk
cool that's that's driving through the
hole gets the bad boys oh man you should
file a lawsuit against them Thank You
reg you're the best you know I love you
did that that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller
jr. the
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]